one of our oldest and most popular
videos just recently celebrated its
fourth anniversary so we made this shirt
to celebrate because you may look at a
tardigrade and you might not assume that
the two of you have a lot in common but
like the Brazilian water bear I think we
all have those days where we feel a
little chubby misunderstood and not
Immortal so if you'd like to pick one up
for yourself you can get them right now
at microcosmos.store
[Music]
thank you
when was the last time you saw a puddle
was it recent perhaps some time in the
past week fresh from a downpour
or has it been a long time since you've
seen rain and so in even longer time
since your path has crossed a puddle
if you can remember do you know what you
did when you saw the puddle did you hop
around it trying to keep your clothes as
pristine as possible or did you have the
complete opposite impulse and jump right
in the middle of it and splashing water
everywhere
or maybe you leaned in closer and
wondered what's in there floating a few
inches away in the shallow depth at the
edge of your feet
if that last one sounds like something
you did or maybe something you wish you
had done you're in good company
everything we're watching today came
from puddles around Warsaw that James
our master of microscopes collected
samples from he waited for two days
after it rained and then wandered from
puddle to puddle so we could collect
water to watch under the microscope
that's where he found these green algae
called pandarina This is not actually
one algae but rather a group of them
bound together in a mucousy shell so
they can form a colony you can see those
individual members of The Colony better
here each a single green cell living a
conjoined existence with its neighbors
given enough light these colonies
quickly reproduce crowding the tiny
puddles that James gathers his samples
from but James is not the first
microscopist to peer into a puddle in
fact if we look at the writings of one
of the original master of microscopes we
can transport ourselves in time and
space to the microcosmos of a 17th
century Dutch puddle I'm of course
talking about Anthony Von lavenhook a
Dutch microscopist whose many letters to
the Royal Society of London contain our
earliest descriptions of microorganisms
or as he called them little
antimolecules
[Music]
when leaving hook first mentioned these
little Ana molecules not everyone
believed him it was one thing to hear
his description of a bee stinger under
the microscope people were familiar with
bees in their stingers but an invisible
world of tiny creatures tinier according
to living hook than the mites found on a
cheese rind well that was harder to
imagine in a letter to the microscopist
Robert Hook lavenhook wrote I suffer
many contractions and oft times here
it's said that I do but tell fairy tales
about the little animals
[Music]
one of leeven Hook's letters started
with the following in 1675 I discovered
living creatures in rainwater which had
stood but few days in a new earthen pot
this rain water along with the sampling
methods observations and experiments
that livenhook described in his letters
would form the basis of his
understanding of the microscopic world
and so in turn it would form the basis
of many others investigations into the
little animals and the world they
inhabit all around us
in a way then every time you see a
puddle you can think of it as a natural
Ode to the early experiments that
introduced us to the microcosmos like
little memorials to the history of
microscopy puddles are more than just
reminders of History though they are
their own little worlds placing demands
on the organisms living inside of them
this cyst for example holds a rotifer
that is slowly waking up from a nap that
had probably protected it from a dry
spell before rain had filled the puddle
back up there is a rhythm to that kind
of Life tied to the wetness surrounding
them in between rains the organisms must
find a way to cope with their dry
environment and when the world around
them becomes wet again the organisms
Thrive like this cilia that's dividing
so it can fill its watery World up with
its clones these are boom and bust
Cycles taken to their extreme to a
million little worlds that go from not
existing to existing when you just add
water
so it's no wonder microscopists have
been drawn to puddles for centuries
these little pop-up microcosmoses that
reveal pockets of Life lying all around
us this video of a vorticella comes to
us from a master microscopist in Florida
named Curtis who was sampling driveway
puddles to watch under the journey to
the microcosmos microscope we can see it
in the middle of our screen perfectly
still with its stock extending long
until something comes along and Spooks
it sending the vorticella rapidly inward
as it contracts back towards the debris
it's attached to
this footage was submitted to us over at
microcosmos dot store where if you're
interested you can submit your own
footage to potentially be used in a
future microcosmos episode because there
are countless worlds all around us
waiting to be seen and shared and we're
looking forward to seeing more of the
worlds around you our fellow masters of
microscopes
and after everything we've learned today
it feels right that the first video we
would be able to share from one of you
comes from a puddle that it comes from a
source that shares so much with the home
of leaving Hook's little inner molecules
despite originating centuries later and
thousands of miles away
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us don't forget right now
you can head on over to microcosmos dot
store both to submit some footage if
you'd like but also to pick up our brand
new tardigrade t-shirt celebrating the
fourth anniversary of our very first
tardigrade video
before we go we also want to thank each
and every single one of our patreon
patrons because without them this show
could not exist and you're seeing some
of their names on the screen right now
and if you would like to join those
names on the screen you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro
if you'd like to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss you
can check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you'd like to see more from us
there's probably a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
thank you